What's the difference between this shot
and this shot?
They're from the same franchise,
just a few years apart.
What exactly is the camera doing
that makes these similar shots
feel so different from each other?
OK, one more.
What about this shot...
and this shot?
Did you catch it?
"Casino Royale" makes two subtle changes
to the cinematography that result in it
looking completely different from all
of the Bond films that precede it.
To find out what exactly it's doing
and why it's doing it, we have to go back
to the beginning of the franchise.
For the overwhelming
majority of Bond films
before "Casino Royale," the cinematography
appears to have been an afterthought.
The lighting was flat,
the composition was boring,
and the cinematography didn't do anything
to advance character or story.
While action scenes adequately
showcased the set pieces
and quality set and production design
helped mask the cinematic shortcomings,
in general, there was very little artistry
put into the cinematography.
James Bond is supposed
to be a super-sleek spy,
but so many of these clunky
and dull-looking scenes
did nothing to further that conceit.
This came to a head
after "Die Another Day,"
when the Bond movie producers decided
to reboot the franchise
and make the next film more
grounded and realistic.
Although a great new actor,
a return to practical effects,
and a stripped-down script
all helped the new dedication to realism,
the cinematography was arguably
the biggest component
that needed an update.
Cinematography is responsible for creating
the look of a film,
dictating the lighting, composition,
and camera movement of every shot.
Studying the film, it becomes clear
that there are two main
principles that guide
the distinctive cinematography
of "Casino Royale":
move the camera and reflect the mood.
So, what exactly does that mean?
To begin, let's talk
about how "Casino Royale"
moves its camera differently
from all other Bond films.
For example, say the
script calls for a scene
where Bond is talking to M.
As M paces around the room,
you could film the scene with
fairly standard coverage,
panning the camera to keep
both her and Bond in frame,
or you could have the
camera track M's movement,
emphasizing her restless mindset
and using a tighter frame to help foster
a connection to her character.
Here's another example:
two scenes that show an establishing shot
of a car arriving at a new location.
Notice how the camera staying
still isn't as engaging.
Viewers' eyes are naturally more attracted
to increased movement.
It's the reason why still images
on television or YouTube videos
often have an added camera zoom or pan.
Compare this first
scene of Bond running...
with this second scene.
Notice how this is much more exciting
and more effectively
conveys urgency and speed.
Here are a couple other things that
intelligent camera movement can do:
exhibit the chaotic
nature of a new location,
amplify a character's dynamic motion,
convey multiple pieces
of information at once,
and the list goes on.
However, adding movement to a shot
doesn't always make it better.
Nonstop camera movement
can be distracting,
and there generally needs to be some sort
of motivation for the camera to move.
For example, this interrogation scene
from "Die Another Day."
Take a look at this
strange camera movement
at the end of the first shot.
There's no reason for the
camera to move to the right.
For all of its great camera movement,
"Casino Royale" still knows
when not to move the camera.
Like early in the film,
when Le Chiffre is playing
poker on his yacht.
The camera is completely stationary,
emphasizing Le Chiffre's full
control of the poker game.
Discussing how camera work
influences the tone of a scene
takes us to "Casino Royale"'s
second principle of cinematography,
reflecting the mood.
Every film has a mood or tone.
In "The Godfather," the story's focus on
its characters' internal
battle between good and evil
is mirrored in its use of
dark and shadowy lighting.
"Lawrence of Arabia"'s
epic story is emphasized
with expansive landscapes and uses
70-millimeter film to
create a massive frame.
The mood of every Bond film is suave.
In each film, Bond goes
around solving mysteries,
picking up women, and narrowly
escaping enemy attacks.
He wears nice suits and has a
very particular drink order.
Bond: Shaken, not stirred.
Narrator: But this
sleek demeanor is rarely
reflected in the drab cinematography.
What the cinematography in
"Casino Royale" does so well
is that it's just as
stylish as its protagonist
for the duration of the film,
emphasizing Bond's sleek nature
and the covert world that he inhabits.
Here's an example.
Let's say there's a
simple line in the script
that describes Bond grabbing a gun
from the glove compartment of his car.
You could do it in two
shots using an insert...
or, if you want to emphasize
the sleek nature of the car,
you can do it all in one shot.
Again, let's say there's
another basic scene
that needs to be filmed.
This time, it's Bond
talking to a woman in bed,
arguably where James
Bond is at his Bondiest.
You could shoot the
scene with flat lighting
and standard composition...
or you could shoot the scene
with stylized lighting,
interesting camera angles,
and then end the scene with
a fantastic shot like this.
And there are many different
ways that "Casino Royale"
uses stylish cinematography
to enhance the film.
It uses lighting to emphasize emotions,
tilted camera angles to
create a sense of imbalance,
and color schemes to
reflect character traits.
Every scene in "Casino
Royale" feels like a scene
that is distinct to a spy movie.
"Casino Royale" is so confident
in the effectiveness of
its sleek cinematography
to capture the essence of Bond
that instead of putting the iconic
animated women in the title sequence,
like every other Bond film,
it creates a better version
of the shot in camera.
And it's shots like this, that combine
camera movement with a
suave cinematic style,
that create some of the
best sequences in the film.
For example, a scene where
a moving camera conveys
the sense of speed and urgency
and the stylish shot
composition adds to the trill.
How about a shot that
expertly communicates
the location and distance
between characters?
Need to have Bond transition
from one conversation to another?
You could do it using several clunky cuts,
or you could do it with
one smooth camera movement.
After the success of "Casino Royale,"
2012's "Skyfall" actually
doubled down on cinematography,
hiring legendary
cinematographer Roger Deakins
to create stunning set
pieces and compositions.
Putting cinematography at
the forefront of the film
was applauded by critics
and audiences alike
and helped "Skyfall" become
the highest-grossing Bond film ever.
"Casino Royale" demonstrates that with
a little bit of extra effort, care,
and strong cinematic principles,
you can completely reinvent
the cinematic look of a franchise
and proves that it's worth the trouble
when you can transform this...
into this.